-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well.
Now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
In a speech last week at the
Volvo truck plant in Maryland,
President Biden said, "Let me
start off with two words --
made in America."
[ Laughter ]
And then it only got worse when
he said, "Sorry, I meant four."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
announced last week
that he will pardon thousands
of individuals
convicted of simple marijuana
possession and said,
"No one should be in jail
just for using
or possessing marijuana,
because, after all,
if you smoke enough marijuana,
your couch is the jail."
[ Laughter ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
convened a meeting today at
his National Security Council.
There were no survivors.
[ Laughter ]
Treasury Secretary Janet Yellen
said in an interview yesterday
that OPEC's decision
to reduce oil output
will harm the global economy.
It's what OPEC is calling
"the point."
[ Laughter ]
At his rally in Nevada
over the weekend,
former President Trump claimed
"two years ago, everything
was so good in our country,
and now it's going to pieces."
Man, I can hardly remember.
I mean, what was
happening two years ago?
Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, those were --
those were good times.
[ Applause, cheers ]
A federal judge in New York
last week issued a ruling
that blocked several parts
of a new state law
that banned guns
in sensitive areas
like museums, stadiums,
and Times Square,
because everyone knows the only
way to stop a bad guy with a gun
is a drunk Elmo
with nothing to lose.
[ Laughter ]
The NFL announced
over the weekend
that it will update
its concussion protocol,
and then in a troubling sign,
they announced it again.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
26% of Americans believe
there should be a minimum age
requirement
for getting ears pierced,
while over in Jersey,
there's a Claire's
in the maternity ward.
[ Laughter ]
That was my favorite one.
I got to be honest with you.
[ Laughter ]
Today was former NFL quarterback
Brett Favre's 53rd birthday,
and even his cake was stolen
from needy children.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, did we ruin his birthday?
[ Laughs ]
And finally, after a video
getting attention online
of a woman in a bikini
getting out of a city fire truck
in front of a strip club,
the mayor of San Jose
announced last week
that an investigation
has been launched,
and the only way
they're getting away with this
is if that woman
was stuck in a tree.
[ Laughter ]
Shot that in Central Park today.
She was great.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.